While we're doing this week is talking,
extending our conversation.
We started last week about how was Paul used as a figure in early Christianity.
Today we're going to talk about the pastoral epistles,
which is first and second Timothy and Titus,
and then next time we'll talk about the acts of Paul and Thecla because these
are two practically opposite ways of interpreting Paul and using Paul.
That came about probably in the second century.
The pastoral epistles are called pastoral because it presents Paul as writing to
Timothy and Titus,
two of his followers,
but he's telling them how to be good pastors of a church.
He's in fact,
he's also doing something like almost acting like they're going to be something.
What would ads would become a bishop.
They're supposed to also be appointing other people as pastors of Churches,
so we call these the pastoral epistles because it presents Paul as himself
serving in a sort of pastoral role for his churches and assigning Timothy and
Titus pastoral roles for his charges also and establishing leadership positions.
What kind of leadership structures he wants to go on in the churches.
Most of us scholars believe that these letters are synonymous.
We don't believe Paul wrote them.
There's been some question in the last several years that may be the actual
historical Paul wrote Second Timothy Because Second Timothy,
uh,
looks sort of like a last will and testament of Paul that he may have written in
prison.
I and then,
but I don't tend to buy that.
I tend to group all three of them together as being probably about the same
author and all being synonymous.
Why do we think they're synonymous?
We all,
again,
as we saw with feeds and Collagen's,
the writing style in these letters is very different from the seven letters that
scholars all agree Paul actually wrote.
So the writing style is a big issue,
but as I'll show today,
there is a lot of way of seeing that these letters simply presuppose a different
stage in early Christianity.
They don't look like they're from the more primitive sort of time of when Paul
was actually founding churches.
So the,
the theology looks different.
This church structure looks different as I'll talk about,
uh,
positions on the household,
on marriage,
on slavery,
on family,
on women.
All of these things are different.
So I'm using the pastoral epistles in this lecture as one illustration of how
Christianity changes in different trajectories.
One trajectory becomes a very much pro household.
The traditional Roman style or Greco Roman family,
uh,
is promoted as the Christian way for families to be.
And even the church itself is molded to look like a household with the potter
Familias,
the head of the household and top women below that,
children in slaves.
Below that when we get to the acts of Paul and Beckla,
we'll see that that interpretation of Paul makes Paul anti household.
He actually is presented as going around preaching against marriage,
against sex,
against the Roman household,
and preaching a very kind of hierarchical disrupting,
even s city Polis,
disrupting gospel and certainly a household and family disrupting apostle.
So these two trajectories of Pauline Christianity show the diversity of
Christianity as it,
as it developed and even how they used the same figure,
Paul as founder of Christianity,
uh,
in radically different ways.
When did these letters come about?
It's everybody's guests.
I act,
I actually tend to think that the pastoral epistles were probably written
sometime in the second century and maybe even toward the middle of the second
century.
That's a bit later than a lot of scholars would put them.
Uh,
and we're just guessing.
Anyway.
We sort of have to imagine,
uh,
what kind of level of early Christianity,
what kind of phase of early Christianity do we imagine,
uh,
taking place before we can get this kind of a letter,
with this kind of theology and church structure written?
It is interesting that when we talked about Marcien early member,
the,
the heretic in Rome who made his own first Canon list of New Testament books,
remember he included Luke as his gospel and his own edited version of it and
included the letters of Paul and marshy.
We don't have any evidence that Marsha and actually knew about these three
letters.
First,
second Timothy and Titus.
If Martian was riding in the middle of the second century,
maybe Marcien if he didn't mention them,
maybe he didn't know them.
And maybe that's evidenced that they weren't yet highly circulated a.
So that's one of the things that people have talked about the dating of these
letters since Marcy and didn't seem to know them.
Perhaps they were either just being written or not long written around the
middle of the second century.
What this author,
the first,
let me back up because I want to go through Paul really quickly and talk about,
uh,
what Paul's own view of the household is.
Look with me in First Corinthians seven.
We're going to review some things that we've gone on before,
but keep your bibles in front of you.
So look at first Corinthians seven.
Okay.
Frustrating in [inaudible] 71 concerning the matters about what you wrote it as
well for a man,
not to touch a woman,
but because of cases of sexual immorality,
each man should have his own wife and each woman,
her own husband,
the husband should give his wife her conjugal rights.
Likewise the wife to her husband.
Notice how Paul balances these things.
He tells basically the man you have control of the body of your wife.
But he also tells to the woman you have control of the body of your husband.
So there's something of a reciprocity in First Corinthians seven,
this will be important because that kind of reciprocity doesn't exist when you
get to the pastoral epistles.
So that's one thing to notice.
Um,
do not verse five,
do not deprive one another except perhaps by agreement for a set time to devote
yourselves to prayer,
come together again so that Satan may not tempt you because of your lack of self
control.
This I say by way of concession,
not of command,
I wish,
I wish that all were as I myself am,
but each has a particular gift from God.
One having one kind and another different kind.
Notice.
He's basically saying have sex within marriage.
He's not condemning sex,
but he really prefers that all Christians be single like he himself is.
So Paul's preference is not marriage and sex and sex within marriage hit.
That's a concession that he gives for people that he says can't control
themselves.
Uh,
to the unmarried and widows.
I say that as well for them to remain unmarried as I am.
But if they are not practicing self control,
they should marry.
It is better to marry than to burn is what the Greek actually says is better to
marry than to burn.
And that's been an interesting question with scholars.
What does it mean by burned?
Does it mean burn in hell that it's better than Mary,
that that'd be tempted to sin a with sex outside of marriage and then you'd burn
in hell.
I've argued that what he means is burn with desire because it was very common in
ancient Greek culture to portray any kind of erotic desire as actually a
physical burning.
They even portrayed it as a disease.
When you start having that itchy feeling that we all know so well,
that's because your body is actually heating up.
And that's what causes that desire.
So they,
in the ancient Greek doctors,
uh,
Greek and Roman doctors gave all kinds of prescriptions to people too,
to keep them to control that burning so they can control their erotic desire
because they felt like it made you actually unhealthy.
It was desire was unhealthy and sexual activity was dangerous.
So this was a concern throughout the ancient world.
And I think that's what Paul is talking about and what I've argued in and have,
uh,
argued this in my Corinthian body book and a few other places,
is that Paul actually prefers that people avoid sex entirely.
Christians avoid checks entirely if they can avoid sex entirely and they're
starting to have sexual desire burning in them,
and that gets dangerous than they should get married and have sex.
But he only to decrease the burning.
What Paul wants is for them to experience sexual intercourse,
even in marriage without any erotic desire.
That's kind of a radical idea,
but I believe that's actually what Paul is teaching here.
That he can seize it possible that Christians could have sex without
experiencing desire.
And that's his goal.
So notice Paul doesn't have a very positive view of sex.
Uh,
even within marriage,
it's a concession.
He allows people and notice,
and none of this passage does,
he hit talk at all about having kids.
Sexuality for Paul is not to make children in,
in Paul's own letters set.
You have sex in marriage only to keep you from desiring.
That's Paul's concern.
That will change later.
So that's one place where we also saw in first Thessalonians four if you'll
remember,
we had the same kind of thing there.
Paul is just talking to the men of the congregation and he says,
don't you start wanting your brother's wife?
She calls him,
is his their school offs,
your vessel.
He says each part,
each of you should have your own vessel.
And the debate is whether he's talking about their genitalia,
which is one possible interpretation with the Greek or their wife's body,
which is another possible interpretation of the Greek.
But for Paul in First Thessalonians four he's telling men also control yourself
and he says,
not in passion of desire like the gentiles.
So there again in first Thessalonians four Paul is really concerned that that
Thessalonians disciples are not lusting after their co,
their fellow Christians,
wife whole keep your own vessel and that's how you control yourself.
And notice again,
he's excluding the idea of passion and desire.
It just does not have a part in it.
So this is,
I admit this is kind of a radical argument and there's a lot of people out there
who haven't bought my argument,
but that seems to me to be precisely what the text is saying.
Paul never allows for a good notion of sexual pleasure or sexual desire.
He seems to want to exclude it in order to keep you from experiencing desire and
he believes that you can do that even by having sex.
So in those ways we see Paul is not anti marriage.
Exactly,
but he's certainly not pro marriage and he's not anti-sex exactly,
but he certainly is not pro sex.
The one thing he does seem to be anti is desire,
sexual desire.
All right,
what is Paul's,
where do women fit in all this?
I pointed out that in first,
Chris,
first Thessalonians four Paul doesn't seem to tinker.
Think about women at all there.
In fact,
they even propose when I lectured on first Thessalonians that by the time wrote,
Paul wrote that letter,
which is one of his earliest letters,
maybe the earliest letter we have in the Canon.
Paul May have been conceiving of the Christian group as being sort of a male
club because that's the way he tends,
tends to be talking to them,
a male club of mainly working class manual laborers.
That's changed by the time we get to first Corinthians,
right?
Because Paul directly talks about women a lot.
He sees women as being in something like a co relationship with their husbands
and sexual activity.
In First Corinthians seven,
he addresses women as leaders of churches at times.
So by the time Paul writes,
First Corinthians,
uh,
women very much are acknowledged as an important part of his churches.
Let's see what he says though.
Uh,
well,
but in First Corinthians 11,
look there
he's not,
he doesn't have women on a completely equal stance with men.
It's apparently in first Corinthians 11,
he says,
I commend you because you remember me and everything and maintain the traditions
just as I handed them onto you.
But I want you to understand that Christ is the head of every man and the
husband is the head of the wife of God is the head of the,
of the church.
There is a clear hierarchy there and Paul goes on to talk about what this is
going to have to do with women veiling their heads when they pray in prophecy,
which is another very complicated and and uh,
uh,
controversial passage in Paul,
but it's clear that Paul views just as he views God as the head of Christ,
that is Christ to being somewhat inferior person compared to God the father.
So women are inferior position with regard to their husbands.
So the Greek words here are not there,
they're just the word for man and woman.
But since the Greek doesn't have special terms for husband and wife,
when are you see a Greek turn like this?
In this context you have to make the decision,
are you going to translate this as man or woman and make this a generic kind of
idea that women in general are supposed to be subordinated to men in general or
do you take the terms and translated them husband and wife?
Both signs license are fine as far as the Greek Ngos and then you're taking that
sort of inferiority subordination complex to be something that's talking about
with husbands and wives.
Look at first Corinthians 14
okay,
get verse 33
as in all the churches of the saints,
women should be silent in the churches for they are not permitted to speak but
should be subordinate as the law also says if there is anything they desire to
know,
let them ask their husbands at home.
British shameful for a woman to speak in church or did the word of God originate
with you or are you the only ones it has reached.
That's odd.
He seems to be telling women not to speak in church at all.
Although previously you'd given instructions for how they could pray and
prophesy in church as long as they are wearing a veil.
What is going on here?
And also then this,
doesn't this have something to say?
Does have some something going to conflict with Galatians three 28 which is a
famous verse in which Paul says,
in Christ there is no June our Greek.
There's no ma,
Ma a free or slave.
There's no male and female.
Now,
that verse has been interpreted,
especially since the 1970s as teaching that Paul taught the equality of men and
women in Christ.
In Christ.
There is no male and female.
Doesn't that mean they're equal?
Yes sir.
Galatians three 28 so this has been the,
that an argument.
This is why I'm,
I'm talking about the stuff.
Those of you who are writing papers this week need to talk about,
but notice this is complex.
You got Galatians three 28 that looks like an egalitarian statement except a
very famous biblical scholar.
Hm.
Wrote an article arguing that Galatians three 28 is not an egalitarian statement
because Paul was talking about in the resurrection human being,
Christians will be Androgens,
that they'll be male,
female,
uh,
combinations.
And in that male,
female combination,
the masculinity is still superior to femininity even in the androgen body of the
resurrection.
So that's is is Galatians three 28 and a gala Terrian statement by Paul.
Some people say yes.
Is it not an egalitarian statement by Paul?
I say it's not,
but that's a complicated argument also.
And if first it's Galatians three 28 is an egalitarian statement,
how does that fit then with this first Corinthians 14 passage where Paul seemed
to be saying women should be silent in church and and be subordinate.
Ask Your husband at home.
Did you,
do any of you noticed that those verses I just read in first [inaudible] 14 are
in some translations in brackets in parentheses.
How many people have a translation of First Corinthians 1434 through 36 that's
in either brackets or parenthesis.
Raise your hand.
How many people have a translation where they're not in brackets or parenthesis?
Anybody.
Okay,
so some of you don't have them in brackets that's showing you that these editors
are not sure whether that was actually part of the original letter.
There's a dispute here.
If you looked at your footnote,
so your Bible,
your footnotes might even say some ancient authorities don't include this or
include these verses in a different place.
And so this is the issue and we do have some Greek texts,
some Greek manuscripts that either don't have these verses or have them in a
different place in the text.
Well,
how would that happen?
the idea goes that some scribe at some point was copying over first Corinthians
14 and got to the point where this isn't a text and wrote out in the margin,
well wait a minute,
this is not right.
Because of course it describes are living at a later time when women definitely,
we're in a more inferior position in churches.
They couldn't be priest that couldn't be bishops in this sort of thing.
And that scribe writes in,
well,
no,
of course women can't do that.
So there's a little note that occurs there on the margins of the text.
Other scribes come along and find this manuscript and they decide,
well that shouldn't be out here in the margin.
That should go into the text someplace.
So one scribe copying it over,
puts that extra expert in this part of the text and another one puts it in this
part of the text in different places and then those manuscripts were copied over
by other scribes and you end up with the Greek manuscripts with this little,
these verses in different places in First Corinthians 14 so some scholars have
said that all looks like those verses that teach the subordination of women in
First Corinthians 14 we're not originally by Paul,
but we're a later scribal interpolation insertion into the text.
Others,
other scholars disagree with that and they think that these two verses,
these verses were original with first graders,
14 in other words,
I've given you a lot of problems to deal with.
If you're going to talk about what was Paul's view of women,
you've got to figure out what,
what do you think Galatians three 28 really teaches?
Is that at a gala Terrian statement or not is first Corinthians 14 these verses
that part of Paul's original teaching or not?
And then you've got the situation where in like Romans 16 several verses in
Romans 16 Paul actually addresses women as leaders of churches.
So there are places where Paul is willing to talk to women as leaders of
churches.
In fact,
one of the verse in First Corinthians 16 Paul addresses to people and drawn to
cuss and Julia and he says,
these are esteemed among the apostles,
among the apostles.
That sounds like he's actually saying that Andronicus and Junia are themselves
apostles.
So,
and Paul thinks he him,
the apostles in Paul's view doesn't include just the 12 right?
Because he thinks he's an apostle and he's not one of the 12th so the p the word
apostle for Paul is wider than the 12 and it refers to people who go out and
spread the gospel.
So apparently Paul is calling to people Andronicus and Junia Apostles in Roman
16.
Interestingly enough,
that word Julia,
that might be in your translation as Julia nowadays,
but in older English versions,
it was translated as Junius,
which would be a man's name in Latin.
If you add an s on that word,
it looks like a man's name.
If you don't have the s,
it looks like a woman's name.
And there was debate among scholars about how to translate it.
It looks the same basically in Greek because of the way the word curves in the
sentence.
But when you translate it,
it are you going to make it a man's name or a woman's name?
And people had always made it a man's name.
Why?
Because scholars just thought,
of course,
all these scholars are men themselves.
Throughout hundreds of years,
they thought,
well,
you can't have a woman apostle,
so it must be a man's name.
And in the 70s,
some feminist feel,
uh,
biblical scholars came along and pointed up that Junius is a very,
very,
very rare man's name.
But Julia is a very common woman's name and argued again through textual
criticism that Paul originally was addressing a woman Julia,
and now you have basically most scholars admitting that this is a woman.
It's a woman's name.
Paul was addressing a man Andronicus and a woman Julia and calling them both
apostles.
There's some,
there's some uh,
evidence.
Depaul actually doesn't have such a negative view of women if he's going to
allow them to have leadership roles in his churches.
So you got Paul and rather confusing situation is Paul's a feminist,
is e four Egalitarian,
uh,
theology with women,
men and women.
How does this relate to these different issues that come in and put his letters?
But those are Paul's basic views of both divorce,
I mean a,
both a marriage and the family and sex and the roles of women and often in early
Christianity in the history of Christianity,
these two things go together.
What a,
what a text is going to teach about the role of women in the church and in the
world often has something to do with what it teaches about the family.
And most of the time when a text is really,
really pro-family,
they teach the subordination of women more directly.
And when they're antifamily,
they often tend to allow women bigger roles in their congregations.
So it's kind of a pairing that goes along,
and that's exactly what we'll see this week when we see the pastoral epistles
that take Paul down the pro family anti-woman route and the acts of Paul and
Thecla,
which takes Paul down the antifamily pro woman route.
Okay,
so let's look at the pastorals first.
What does this author in First Timothy attacking,
and I'm gonna say most of my time in first Timothy because that's where I can
get these examples.
A lot of this stuff occurs in the letter to Titus also because the letter to
Titus repeats a lot of the stuff that's in the first letter of Timothy
in one three.
I urge you as I did when I was in on my way to Macedonia to remain in FSS so
that you might instruct certain people not to teach any different doctrine,
not to occupy themselves with myths and endless genealogies that promote
speculations rather than the divine training that is known by faith.
So myths and vain discussions and genealogies.
Uh,
he,
in seven he talks about godless and silly myths.
Titus one 10 and 14 also.
And then he also in Titus says that he's against people who are teaching
circumcision and Jewish myths.
He calls him,
well,
what are these myths?
Well,
we're not really sure.
Are these sort of a gnostic type myths about different,
many different gods doing things and having to placate those gods in order to
reach the highest God.
As we've seen in some gnostic texts,
uh,
that we talked about earlier in the semester,
we don't know,
but there's some kind of stories about either angels or Gods that some people
are teaching and this author's writing against it and some and some aspect of
somethings Jewish about this.
He doesn't like.
Look at four first Timothy four one
yeah.
Now the spirit expressly says that in later times,
in the latter days,
some will renounce the faith by paying attention to deceitful spirits and
teachings of demons through hypocrisy of liars whose consciences are seared with
a hot iron.
They forbid marriage and demand abstinence from foods which God created to be
received with Thanksgiving by those who believe and know the truth.
So this author is against people who are challenging marriage.
He's against people who are challenged,
who are promoting some kind of ascetic behavior with regard to foods or avoiding
certain kinds of foods.
Is this cash route?
Maybe he's talking about people who are teaching people not to eat pork,
not to eat shellfish.
Are they teaching Jewish food laws?
He's not explicit.
So he's against people who are teaching that he's against people who are
forbidding marriage and teaching any kind of dietary restrictions.
Look at five 23
okay,
this is when he tells Timothy,
no longer drink only water,
but take a little wine for the sake of your stomach and your frequent ailments.
Why is he at to tell somebody to drink some wine and not just drink water?
Well,
because there were a sedex who taught to avoid wine in the angel world.
That was one of those things that very strict ascetics might decide to avoid was
wine and rich food.
So this author says to Timothy,
nope,
you should drink wine.
This was our favorite verse when I grew up in a church that didn't allow
drinking.
Of course,
I always like to throw this back at the elders of the church.
Look at six 21st Timothy six 20 Timothy Guard.
What has been entrusted to you?
Avoid the profane chatter and contradictions of what is falsely called
knowledge.
What is the Greek word for knowledge?
Pardon?
No,
exactly.
See,
you're getting more than you paid for in this course.
You didn't know you were going to learn Greek.
You get in some good cocktail party information and even some Greek language.
So gnosis is the word for knowledge here.
And uh,
this guy saying he's attacking people who are going around boasting about
falsely called knowledge.
Again,
that's led some scholars to say,
is he talking about some kind of gnosticism?
Is that what he's opposing?
That would go along with this idea that they're using this word gnosis in ways
he doesn't like their teaching myths.
They're teaching asceticism.
They're teaching the voting to marriage.
Well,
that does look a bit like early other,
early Christian,
second century Christian groups,
some of whom their opponents would call gnostics,
but we don't have enough information to be ready to,
easy to tell them.
Now look at one more text.
This is second Timothy two 18.
Yeah.
Oh,
let's see.
Yeah.
He's talking about,
he's actually giving some names of people he doesn't like in two 18 says these
people have swerved from the truth by claiming that the resurrection has already
taken place.
Hi,
he's,
he's contending that.
So remember how I even talked about with Collagen's in Ephesians last time you
had this idea that uh,
they almost sound like the resurrection has already taken place in your baptism
with Christ.
You had been raised with Christ and maybe there are other people running around
the second century Christians saying that you've already been raised from the
dead.
You've already expensed resurrection.
This author really condense that.
He wants to say,
no,
the resurrection hasn't taken place yet.
So he's condemning you can false teachers for all kinds of,
uh,
different activities and teachings that he doesn't like.
So we're seeing a definite split here between different kinds of pollinization.
There's a pollen isn't represented by these texts,
which is pro family pro-marriage,
uh,
pro procreation.
We'll talk about see later that he's,
he's for having children and mentions as explicitly,
um,
anti asceticism against,
uh,
you know,
con forcing people to control what they eat on these sorts of things.
And this idea about maybe Jewish myths being something and the teaching of the
resurrection.
First Timothy one nine then gets us into another issue.
What is the law and what is this authors take on it?
One nine.
This means that one eight I'll start this verse eight.
Now we know that the law is good if one uses it legitimately.
Now of course,
that can be quotation right out of Romans,
right?
Because Romans itself has,
Paul says,
the law is good.
This means understanding that the law is laid down not for the innocent,
but for the lawless and disobedient for the godless and sinful,
for the unholy and profane for those who killed their father or mother or
murderers,
fornicators,
sodomites,
slave traders,
liars,
perjurers,
whatever else,
contrary to sound teaching that contradicts the Gracious,
the Glorious Gospel of the blessed God,
which he entrusted to me.
Notice this guy doesn't have really a problem with the law that we've seen
sometimes in Paul's writings.
The law is basically just a set of rules in that designed to keep people who
can't control themselves in line.
And in fact,
he goes on to say that if you're a good person,
you don't even need to worry about the law.
Now this is again different from what Paul's view is.
Paul did not want his,
his gentile followers to keep the Jewish law,
and Paul said in Romans,
the law is good,
but Paul,
for Paul,
the law is still this cosmic entity almost that that was invaded history.
This is very much Galatians memory.
When we,
I gave the lecture on Galatians and Romans,
I talked about how that the Jewish law for Paul is not simply a list of rules.
It was this thing that came into the cosmos as an invader.
It enslaved humanity.
It was the pedagogue that you know,
swatted humanity down when humanity was in its child,
childish state.
The law is,
is obeying.
The law for Paul is equal to trying to worship this Stoy Kayah of the cosmos,
these elemental spirits of the universe.
So the law for Paul isn't simply a list of rules.
The law for Paul is a very ambiguous cosmic entity.
It's almost,
it's just mythological in a sense for Paul,
for this author,
that's not what the law is,
the law.
You don't need to obey it.
He says,
and he's against,
uh,
teaching his gentile converts to keep the Jewish law.
But he just says it's not important.
It's only for people who,
who are sinners,
who can't control themselves.
As long as you're not a center,
as long as you don't do this list of things that I can give you,
you don't need to concern yourself about the law.
So this is another one of the reasons that people like me say this is not Paul
writing.
People who believe Paul wrote these letters would say,
well,
they're written years later,
is to a different context.
And Paul changed his mind,
or Paul's nuancing his message differently for a different context.
So there are scholars who would defend these letters are being by Paul and
that's what they would say.
I look at and I say that's so not like Paul is a totally different view of the
law and its role in the cosmos.
Then you see in Romans or Galatians,
which is another piece of evidence for me that Paul's not the author of this
letter.
Okay,
pulse.
The strategy then of this author,
he's trying to argue against all kinds of myths and practices that that somebody
going through Paul's churches and teaching,
so he writes a letter in Paul's name seemingly addressed to this,
to Paul's follower Timothy and he lays out what he doesn't like about that,
but that's not the all,
all of his strategy because what is his strategy for combating these things that
he considers false teachings.
First he makes the church itself a household.
Now this is where all that lecturing,
the first part of the semester when I talked over an argument,
what is the patriarchal household?
What is the Roman household?
Was the potter Familias?
What is the structure of the household?
What is the patron client relationship?
What is the role of wives and women in the household and children and slaves?
All of that was because when you get to some of these are aspects of early
Christianity.
This author is using the Roman household as the model for the church itself.
That wasn't the way Paul did it,
right?
Paul never talked about the church as if it just had the same structure of a
household.
He didn't talk about men always being on top of the leadership organization and
he doesn't,
didn't promote marriage very much.
What this author does,
three 15
I hope to come.
This is three 14 first Timothy three 14 I hope to come to you soon,
but I'm riding these instructions to you so that if I'm delayed,
you may know how one ought to behave in the household of God,
which is the Church of the living God,
the pillar and bulwark of the truth.
The church is the household of God.
That same thing happens in first Timothy five the beginning of [inaudible] 85 do
not speak harshly to an older man.
Speak to him as a father to younger men,
as brothers to older women,
as mothers to younger women as sisters with absolute purity.
Notice he's got everybody in the church has some familial role.
Older guys are fathers.
You're a younger men in the Church of your brothers,
younger women's sisters,
older women,
mothers,
everybody has a household role in the church.
This is different.
We,
we might think this is automatic,
but notice this is not treating the church as an Ekklesia,
that Greek word that we translate church.
Where did the term Ekklesia come from?
Do you remember?
In Greek,
what does the term Ekklesia originally referred to in classical Greek,
the assembly of the city.
It's the assembly of the city state that came together for political purposes
into vote.
It comes out of the Greek democracy with its notions of,
of uh,
of some,
some kind of equality among citizens and all that.
At least the men citizens getting a vote.
So it's important that early Christians for some reason chose this word Ekklesia
to describe their house churches.
It was an outsider with might've thought this is kind of ridiculous.
You're using.
The term that people would have heard is the town assembly for a few people who
can fit into one dining room.
It's kind of,
you know,
a seating more important to yourself then you really should,
but I think it's important that early Christian groups use that term for
themselves.
Why didn't early Christian groups call themselves synagogues?
That was a term already in use by Jews.
It would have been a normal term to use,
but we don't find many early Christians using the term synagogue for their
groups.
We do find them using Ekklesia very quickly,
but in Ekklesia isn't a household.
What this author is doing is shifting in a not so subtle way.
Understanding these house groups as being more like town assemblies and making
them look more like Roman households.
Then also then row men have certain roles.
Then first 72 eight
yeah,
I desire them that in every place the men should pray lifting up holy hands
without anger argument also that the women should pray lifting up.
Holy hands.
The argument,
no,
Dale's lying to you again,
the women should dress themselves modestly,
decently in suitable clothing.
Not with their hair braided girls.
Your last name
or with gold pearls are expensive clothes,
but with good works as is proper for women who profess reverence for God.
Let a woman learn in silence with full submission.
I permit no woman to teach or have authority over a man she has to keep silent
for.
Adam was foreign first,
then eve and Adam was not deceived,
but the woman was deceived and became a transgressor.
Yet she will be saved through childbearing provided they continue in faith and
love and holiness with modesty.
Now,
that's kind of a,
this is something that my mom used to hate it when they'd preach about this in
church
and also it's controversial.
Does it mean that she's saved in from the dangers of childbirth?
That's one way of reading.
It shall be saved from the dangers of childbirth.
If she lives a pie as a holy life or a bit more of a radical way of reading,
it would be to say her by having babies,
women help constitute their own salvation.
That having children is one ways that women's save themselves.
Either way.
You look at it,
this author really wants women to be in a subordinate role,
silent in church.
They can't have any leadership authority.
You're teaching authority over a man as we'll see.
They do have some offices,
there are roles that women can play in the pastoral epistles but not in
authority over men.
And then there's this odd thing about childbearing that somehow,
and I think what it means is that childbearing actually can help save women,
uh,
from there,
sins in some way.
So that's what women have to be modestly dressed,
no jewelry,
save through childbearing
in order to maintain this kind of household structure,
a very hierarchical household structure.
This author sets up offices in the church and here's what I want.
Another reason we call these the pastoral epistles cause he's setting up
pastoral offices.
Look in three,
one through seven.
This saying is sure,
whoever aspires to the office of Bishop desires a noble task.
Now a bishop,
anybody have a different translation for what I just read?
His bishop.
Overseer.
Yes.
Overseers.
A translation.
Anybody have a different translation?
Yeah.
Cause there were bishop here is,
it's the,
the Greek word is episcopals.
Wherever we get the English word bishop and you get the name for the episcopal
church cause it's a church that has PR,
has bishops.
Um,
in Greek it basically means an overseer.
Someone in charge.
The bishop must be above reproach.
Married only once.
Temperate,
sensible,
respectable,
hospitable and APP teacher.
Not a drunkard,
not violent,
but gentle.
Not Quarrelsome,
not a lover of money.
He must manage his own household well,
keeping his children submissive and respectful in every way for if someone does
not know how to manage his own household,
how can you take care of God's church?
Again,
the church is a household.
If you're going to be the bishop over the church,
you have to be married because how can you manage the household,
the church,
if you can't prove it by managing your own household?
Well,
he must not be a recent convert.
Baba Baba Baba.
So the bishop or the episcopals is already himself now a male head of household.
The other office,
he talks about in five 17 let the elders now just as the word were translated,
bishop or overseer
comes from the Greek word episcopals
true.
The Greek for elder here is pres Butoh Ross presbyter,
and this is where the Presbyterian church gets the name of his church,
if they're Presbyterians,
because the Presbyterian church rejected the use of bishops like they found in
the Catholic and Anglican churches and chose a plurality of elders.
So they're called elders and a Presbyterian church.
And the Presbyterian church comes from this Greek word [inaudible],
meaning elder Presbyt duress.
And this is actually,
this came to be later in English,
the name for a bishop who was not just the,
the head of one particular church,
but became the head of a series of churches,
a bunch of churches.
That is the bishop and now is not the head of one church,
but the head of a whole diocese that has a grouping of geographical grouping.
So the,
the words changed a bit,
but that's bishop comes from this word and pres boot or US turned into the word
priest.
So an edamame,
one of the suggested etymologies for where that the English word priests kings
from is from this Greek word itself.
You can kind of say Pres Butaro,
Presbyterian,
presbyter Pres Boudreau priest,
right?
Just kind of happens in English over,
you know,
a few hundred years.
So elders are also have to,
um,
have wives be family men and all this sort of thing.
There are other offices to look at real quick.
They're going to go through this.
Deacons.
Three,
eight deacons likewise,
must be serious,
not double tongue,
not indulging in much wine,
not greedy for money.
They must hold fast to the mystery of the faith with a clear conscience.
Let them first be tested.
Then if they proved themselves blindness at them,
serve as deacons.
Women,
likewise,
must be serious.
Now there's an exegetical problem.
Does this women refer to women who were themselves independently be deacons?
In other words,
is he allowing women to be deacons on their own?
Or is this supposed to be taken to be just the wives of the male deacons that
they're called deacons or deaconesses?
That word for Deacon here comes from the Greek word [inaudible].
Okay.
C D arch,
Deacon Jaak Anos Deacon
comes into English directly.
So,
and that we're just means a servant,
someone who serves or ministers.
So the women in three 11,
some extra genes would say this shows that this author does allow at least women
to have to be roles as deacons deaconesses and they have certain kinds of roles.
Uh,
let verse 12 let deacons be married only once.
Let them manage their children are households.
Well for those who served well as deacons get a good standing for themselves.
So notice in the beginning all of these,
uh,
roles,
whether it's the elder presbyter or the bishop,
and there's some debate about whether Presbyterian,
it refers to the same role as a bishop.
In these letters,
they seem to be combined and some of the layer pastoral letters or whether
they're for to two separate offices.
So there's a bit of a debate.
But anyway,
all of these people where they are,
you're talking about bet bishops,
presbyters deacons,
they all are required to be married and all are required to have children.
So in the beginning of early Christianity,
see,
you did not have the celibate ministry to celebrate ministry comes about later
and,
but this is in line with this author's intention to set up the church as a
household structure with men on top women having their own roles.
Now there are other roles here,
uh,
to look at five three through 10.
Yeah,
honor widows.
This is firstly with e five three honor widows who are really widows.
If a widow has children or grandchildren,
they should first learn their religious duty to their own family and make some
repayment to their parents.
For this is pleasing in God's sight.
The real widow left alone has set our hope on God and continues and
supplications and prayers night and day.
But the widow who lives for pleasure is dead even while she lives.
Give these commands as well so that they may be above reproach.
Whoever does not provide for relatives and especially for family members has
denied the faith and is worse than an unbeliever.
Now it gets really interesting.
Let a widow be put on the list,
let her be registered.
Ah,
this is a way of,
it seems like he's actually creating another kind of office in the church that
is the office of widows and sure enough in Christianity later widow became
almost like an office in early Christianity.
There can be,
they can be registered and they receive financial help from the churches.
Let a widow be put on the list if she is not less than 60 years old and has been
married only once.
Notice over and over here we've seen this thing about being married once.
Apparently this author believes in marriage and once we will be married,
but his ideal is that people should be married once you shouldn't.
You certainly should not be divorced and remarried.
Paul himself a forbids people in his church from being from being divorced and
remarried as we saw in First Corinthians 11 but this author seems to say that if
you're married and your spouse dies,
he still kind of prefers that these women to be married once.
He also said that the bishop or the predators should be men who are married only
once.
So multiple marriage is really frowned on even though marriage itself is highly
valued.
This led to what is currently the practice and many of the eastern churches,
eastern Orthodox or the Greek Orthodox,
the Russian Orthodox,
they do not forbid their priest from being married,
but you have to be married before you become a priest.
So you'll have a lot of young men and Greece or Russia who are going to become
priest and they want to quickly get married right out of seminary.
They're looking around for a partner because if they become ordained as a priest
and they're not married,
they're expected to stay on married and if their or wife dies after they become
a priest,
they're expected to stay celibate and single for the rest of their lives also.
So this led to the tradition in eastern Christianity that you can be a married
priest,
unlike the Roman Catholic church,
but only if you get married before you become a priest.
And it kept this idea of being married once only,
I can't go into the rest of this,
but notice how this whole hierarchy of man and woman in the household,
old and young is also extended to children and slaves already in collages.
In Ephesians we had what we call the household household codes.
Met Masters,
treat your slaves well.
Slaves be obedient to your masters.
Husbands treat your wives well.
Wives submit to your husbands,
children submit to your father's father.
His treats are general.
So these are called household codes and already in Colossae and Ephesians they
set up the household in a clear hierarchical,
patriarchal situation that is intensified in the pastoral epistles.
You have much longer household codes and whereas in Collagen's in Ephesians that
Rye,
those writers at least said there was some reciprocity.
They would,
they would address the slaves.
You have to obey the master,
but they would also address the master and say,
treat your slaves.
Well,
when you get to the pastoral epistles,
they left out the reciprocity.
It's mainly directed to the slaves,
to the children,
to the wives saying,
submit.
So this is the strategy that this writer uses to combat the forms of
Christianity that he doesn't like,
is to construct the house,
the church as a rigid patriarchal household in which each person has a role.
Even young women,
he says they're not supposed to be enrolled as widows.
If you have one women,
young women who are widows and they start running around gossiping,
getting lot of trouble,
he says,
get them married off again.
Old Women.
Of course you couldn't marry off again.
There are not enough old men around in ancient Loda Merrim off so you,
he creates this structure by which women,
older women get pulled back into the household.
By this role as widows,
no matter what happens to a woman in this op authors view,
they have to be put back into their submissive place in the household structure,
even if that means creating a new role for them called widows.
This is this strategy this author uses to bring Paul into his own time.
He's taking appall that we sent.
Scene is a bit different from this,
and he's reinventing Paul for a second century Christian environment and
restriction the church as the household.
We'll see an author on Wednesday doing precisely the opposite with Paul.
See you next time.